No,
a couple of days after the remembrance
of d day on the sixth of June,
1944.
I think it is a good moment to reflect
upon how alive we'll talk to still is in
our culture and in our hearts.
Although every year there are new films
and TV stead deal with the Second World
War.
The most defining of the last decades is
still by far saving private Ryan.
The movie has taken an important role in
the public memory of words or to ask
Mathias fiedler states now that the
generation that fought in the war is
slowly leaving us.
Our post memory of the war becomes
increasingly reliant on mediated images
of the past.
Those were two movies hold a cultural
position where they actively engaged
younger generations with the older
generation that experienced and fought
in the war.
Ryan moonroof rq,
Istats,
watching,
saving private Ryan became a cultural
event where different generations
sometimes saw the movie together and
then discuss some of the pain and trauma
that came with remembrance.
Marianna Hirsch has coined this practice
where younger generations engaged with
traumatic memories of all the
generations to cultural artifacts as
post memory.
Now,
to make an argument about how Saving
Private Ryan Folks Post Memory,
we have to look at how the movie creates
a connection between the audience and
the characters on screen since the
characters represent the soldiers that
fought in world war two.
We can do this by exploring Marie Smith
structure or sympathy moray device
audience identification with cinematic
characters into central imagining and
essential imagining.
Central imagining is when the audience
literally fuels while to characters on
screen feel fear,
anger,
happiness,
etc. This is what's buber primarily
tries to achieve in the opening sequence
of saving private ryan
using the handheld shaky cam that moves
and tax to the violence on the beach.
Spielberg simulaTes the actual
experience of a soldier in the middle of
it as the camera functions as the eyes
of the viewer,
humorous made to feel as if he is in the
middle of the violence and trauma of
war.
Closing the gap between the audience and
the characters on screen.
Spew book then in fights is food into
the subjective experience of the
soldiers on screen by using sound
effects that conveyed the shell shock of
the soldiers
central imagining,
however asked me criticized since it is
impossible,
achieve it completely in spite of all
the cinematic techniques,
the audience contrary to the characters
on screen and soldiers they represent
back in 1944,
is still safely watching in a theater,
turning the violence and horror of war
into spectacle.
Therefore,
one straw to foa one stated that there
is no such thing as an antiwar movie.
Stills,
spielberg takes a mighty shots at
evoking an effective central imagining
and not completely successful,
I would say since there were reports or
federal having ptsd attacks.
Upon screening a movie,
it is clear that spielberg has in a way
succeeded in having us audience
experienced the horrors of war.
Contrary to central imagining a or
imagining is where the fewer stones
literally fueled the same things as the
characters.
Birth.
Instead,
sympathize with their experience.
Smith subdivides this into recognition,
alignment and allegiance recognition
being simply recognizing characters as
who they are,
men,
women,
american soldiers,
german soldiers,
etc.
Alignment is when the audience gets
access to the experience and thinking of
the characters,
and allegiance is when the audience has
evaluated the characters moral choices
and start rooting for them.
I would argue that safe and private
ryan's narrative structure is designed
to have the audience build a strong
allegiance with the characters on
screen.
After the opening sequence,
the film narrows in on a small group of
soldiers.
Those costs were 12,
saving private ryan.
Throughout the film,
we stay close to these men and their
experiences creating a lot of time to
bond with them.
Saving private ryan is not unique in
this many war films focus on a small set
of characters in the myths of huge
historical offense as stalin wants.
Sets one.
Death is a tragedy.
A million deaths is a statistic in
saving private ryan.
The audience connects strongly with a
small group of soldiers.
She has these characters represent the
american soldiers in world war two as a
whole.
This is a much more effective way of
evoking posts memory,
dan,
for example,
90,
60 to the longest day where we see dna
from a lot more angles and with a lot
more characters.
This gives some more complete oversight
of dda,
yet it feels to establish a strong
connection between the audience and the
characters on screen and this who they
represent.
Finally,
saving private ryan begins and ends with
a scene of private ryan in current day
attending the crosses of his fallen
saviors.
This is a clear reminder to the
audience.
They're the generation that followed in
and survived the second world war is
still among us.
I was arguing with speed work and tom
hanks achieved the same effect even
better in band of brothers and two
pacific.
My opens each episode with interviews of
the actual soldiers that are portrayed
on screen.
My generation is I think the last
generation that can personally talk to
veterans of world war two.
As roy metcalfe states,
the gis are leaving us now,
leaving us a priceless legacy and this
the responsibility of keeping a life.
Their experiences in our cultural memory
will rest more and more upon the films
and series that's portrayed him.
Thank you all for watching.
This video turned out a little bit
different than our plans since I wanted
to compare saving private ryan tuerck
german show called muto until father a
that uses the same techniques to give a
different perspective on the german side
of the war.
It has to audience sympathize with
normal german soldiers also being fixed
in terms of the nazi regime.
Uh,
unfortunately german copyright law made
it impossible anyway.
If you want to support us,
consider doing alto patron or consider a
onetime donation,
a followers and facebook,
etc. And we will see you next week.